and ton Lee he uh submission heel hooked
he trains with Ryan Hall yeah and boom
he got that right away yep Mikey Mushi
doing the damn thing of course y he had
a little bit of a weight issue too going
in right he didn't make weight the first
time was it Mikey or who Mikey yeah oh I
don't he was sick yeah yeah he has
something going on with him and he
always has like I always see him with
like a dark black eye I don't know if
that's part of his pra from tapping
hoose out yeah Mikey got it done again
the legend of Mikey continues pizza and
Jiu-Jitsu that's what we he's insanely
good yeah Championship doing the damn
thing on Amazon Prime